[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to another week of games what play for
all on today's charity stream I'm joined
by a very special guest face mom herself
red Ford from Digital Extremes
red pillow how's it goin good thank you
how are you pretty good ready to do some
very very devious things on this play
for all stream today I was gonna say so
what are we gonna be doing today I'm
very excited the premise of this one we
have a unreleased game mode that only
the devs can use right now that allows
us as devs to invade our players
missions in real time and fight them so
we are going to be putting my
non-existent skills to the test to to
entertain and you know bring joy to the
world today saying bring joy but take
out a bunch of people so how can people
in the chat take part because obviously
the yet like you said this is a dev only
build this is the only way you can get
to play it how can people take pop so
the way it works is if you are familiar
with warframe you know it's a big free
free-to-play sci-fi game you're out
there running your missions if you want
me to come invade them on PC right now
because this is pc only dev tools you
just need to in chat tell me your pc
alias and of course you need to be on
public matchmaking because of course we
cannot invade you if you don't want us
to so if you're in a mission with public
matchmaking if you give us your name we
can simply come and find you and hunt
you down but you got to be in a mission
and it has to be public so we're doing
this I will say this upfront and I'll be
saying it throughout the stream we're
doing this for charity we are raising
money for two great causes one of which
is black lives matter you can donate at
the link bellow I /gs - BLM or - Direct
Relief who are doing providing frontline
health care workers with protective
clothing as well as support during the
covert 19 pandemic so if you'd like to
donate to them the URL is on screen
below - it's bit ly /gs - kovat if you
donate on the stream we're reading out
all the lovely messages you've been
leaving and let's raise some money but
more but also let's invade some people
let's do this so that's I'm super
excited
the charity component as well and I
think the invasions are you know that
people might be a little shy and be
unsure of exactly if I can take them on
and the answer's yes I can
so we just need to get some names so
we'll let them trickle in and get
everyone acclimated to the imminent
threat that is me invading their house
easy don't be shy
this would be a lot of fun and also yeah
I want to see you put your skills to the
test because I'm watching your kind of
live feed at the same time are so I'm
gonna be here oh we've got a couple come
in on the YouTube chat so do you want
ice is nice there is a mezzo m5 do do
Capitals count you know it's not
case-sensitive so I just need to know
the name as you spell it out cool Emme
Zed Zed om5
all right here we go
maybe if their admission I might need to
turn on one or two settings before that
works oh maybe they're not in a mission
mm see I might need to turn if that
didn't work at mezzo m5m is it not
coming out yep we're in right we're in
all right so this is mezzo from the
YouTube chat on GameSpot here we go
mezzo so it's PC only right now because
of the the dev hacks involved so PC
players are free to give their names
once they are in a public mission that's
it oh hello okay so what you're seeing
here is I get to decide where I spawn
perfect Oh God can you left for dead II
a Larry left for dunya laughs a deadiy
like left for dead left for dead it's a
verb so now I'm in and I can try and
take it down if he wants you a we can we
can gamify this a little bit for
everyone i get i will donate five
dollars to both charities perfect okay
thank you very much and i will match you
my notepad and pen so we can keep track
of this also this puts a little more
pressure on you I don't but you do do
this yourself I did boldy was a thing if
they beat me you donate five dollars if
I get if I get it all donate I like that
I like oh I got their shields down um
this game has a lot of parkour if you
didn't know so we will uh oh my gosh
so I a few hours into a good few hours
into wolf range and I felt like I was
just getting to the point where I had
kids I don't be a possible fight and
like pop all around and obviously cool
and this is just basically showing me
that no I was not meaning I'm not nearly
as good as I thought I was either but
that that doesn't change the fact that I
tried very hard and I did get them down
a bit but warframes are very strong it's
basically the ultimate power fantasy
surfer for one feeble person like me to
try and take on a warframe is foolish
but okay
Congrats Mezo /i well then you two bees
name is Isis nice 286 congratulations to
you bye why don't you alright rhino pala
in the chat blood for the blood god
skills for the scope room people we will
appease these gods will get him uh
Dallas doc asks um is this game-mode
actually gonna come to Wolfram or is it
just gonna be a dev only built it's been
dev only for the better part of three
years now I'm not saying it's never
gonna ship but we have a lot of other
things to ship as well that are more
expected so maybe soon maybe not I'm I
will strongly suggest that for it's
gonna be definitely for just a little
bit longer so if you if you want to play
now is your chance basically do you
wanna grab one from the twitch chat yeah
I'm just alternating my mine was
actually not loading so my mistake there
but hopefully this all right so oh I see
what happened
alright twitch chat anyone in there
ready for PC of course public missions
and we will we will get it going
I am I eat all right no names I don't
know if my chat is oh is it alive it
we've got we got a bunch on gamespot
YouTube chat so you might need to keep
grabbing those because I might
let's do 0 Xion just cool name
0 ZN z z a o o z IA n said a ro said I
am target not mission that means you
need to G in a public mission public
mission
oho someone in twitch chat sad they're
not at home to play sorry um oh wait I
just saw Isis nice says umm great fight
Reb you were really Wiggly that's thank
you that's the only defensive strategy I
have zero Xion he get in mission public
mission to have a public matchmaking
session oh I got someone let me go ahead
out Bob khun's there we go I got someone
on twitch chat we got a hit
alright we got a hit we're taking down
Travis TSP who is a very meme savvy
player so hopefully they don't turn this
into a meme but you know what do you
mean by meme savvy every stream you they
they've reply with something totally
embarrassing has happened you know like
they they get you the clip it out yep
alright I'm in the void with them this
is our pristine gold and white
environment
oh no oh no oh no they know where I
spawn oh okay we're taking on two
enemies in this one so we have a
multiplayer action here oh oh wait hang
in so it's two on one yeah I can
probably still do I think you got this
oh dear oh no they got me community
community to live inside of my notebook
is just stuff
I want to do in my week off in my room
you know just normal week off things my
taxes
oh all fun and important things so in
this case they took me out very quickly
and I think we're gonna see that right
side of the column grow increasingly
stronger oh we have someone in YouTube
chat who is ready mo Ali Khan so MOA al
i KH am
they're ready they're in a public it
can't be a rail Jack mission if you're
in a rail Jack mission it says you're
not in mission but I will try again and
again it's PC so stock mo Ali Khan mmm
mmm let me write a message and say
hmm we just need PC usernames if you're
in a mission I would go in stock
innocent bystanders but I feel like
that's just a bit too cruel but we could
there's good but but it's it's a level
of them of evil that I don't know if my
my lawful good self can do on stream and
it's a Monday to you you want to set
someone's week off with like oh I got
invaded in warframe and now I'm sad I
mean if they killed me maybe it'll make
their week but if I killed them it could
create a problem all right um okay let's
try mo Ali Khan one more time
mo e mo e a li ke h am got it
target not mission hmm we have someone
else who says they're in mission okay
Mitch Tech so MIT CH T e ce que te CK
target not mission you gotta have PC
public mode and in omission but we will
keep trying because there's people on
Twitch that saw me do this to other
people the other day so they know they
know the the end though they do let's
see if anyone in twitch chat I'm
watching the game spot twitch chat wants
to join
I'll try image Tech again target on
mission okay let's see we've got
common L who said I'm I'm still waiting
come and get me
so eighty am
a n e l
and
oh no maybe target not mission it loaded
a T a n a a TA M film movies gotcha
a n for November al
see it's searching a same target not in
mission maybe if they know what mission
they're in I can probably do it
organically but because I can also just
go to the node they're in so if people
want to just go to a public mission on
oxy moko let's say and avoid I could
just go there and join let's see why
that wouldn't be working let's see if
Mitch tech works again as well
mmm let's see yeah the rules are a
little and again this is why it's not
shipped but they are very strict so that
only public matchmaking sessions on the
normal star chart we can invade so that
means if you find yourself on PC right
now looking at the map here looking at
any of these missions I can I can come
get you but I need a the usernames or I
can just go and say if people go to
oximeter there Oh
so the Rosine says I'm in Mott void
common all right all right
mod isn't there okay do I oops is arose
Ian oh maybe that's why it's not working
because mont is not on the on the path
right now
Oh teresting oh that's because there's
no one there that's eligible so it only
shows the nodes if a user is there in a
public setting so only three nodes are
open right now for for me to stock
Goshen he sounds like people are scared
of me that's the impression I'm getting
okay so someone we've got another one
and like a new name if you want to try
it they said that in mission F six four
eight zero six two
PC only forward need zero six two we're
in okay
oh my macking my hacky ways how come it
might take a second but I think I saw it
load yep we're good tamal asks do you do
this just on weekends by yourself not
even on a stream i I want to say yes
just some mystique and myths around it
but no I don't know like a ronin like
like some kind of ninja just like going
in and taking everyone out quietly oh no
I mean I feel like oh okay we're in I
see we're all right
yeah we're in f6 for 800 60 was running
away from me but I want them I'm gonna
start not noting down people's user
names as they kind of come through
because we're getting quite a few on the
youtubes okay okay so i gave him some
bleep rocks oh I almost got it my awful
spot I was got him I got him
that's one for me missions buzzword in
the day thank you thank you um Oh
cavalry says just tell us an ode to
flock to okay why would ya if everyone
goes on a public matchmaking setting if
we all had let's go to Pluto if everyone
goes to outer terminus you can go there
1v1 me out of terminus no weapons no
mates let's do it slappers only
um okay what else we go we go glacial
and glacial
[Music]
I'm gonna try I'm gonna head to outer
terminus and see what happens
otama della waiting for punish for blood
on my hands
Caliban Uranus that's what they want me
to go I think so
oh there's no one there I can't there's
no one there um okay people are heading
to Pluto geminus sounds good
all right we're gonna we're gonna hit it
we've refreshed it we're going in see
what happens Alice do you think you've
put into Wolfram over the years me yeah
if you genuinely had to here to make a
guess there's three states of ours I've
put into it there's like the public bill
that I play for fun and then there's the
test build and then there's the dev
build so combined probably close to
4,000 oh it's like - like maybe just
under 2,000 on the public build the rest
are likely distributed across dev and
test from any number of things so it's
easily my most played game of all time
oh yeah what what is your like at this
point in time in your career in your
life playing games what is your most
played game of watch oh yeah so I'm
about across two platforms like over 500
hours into overwatch which is not
actually that much in the ground even
things like what like what but um I
don't know it feels like it's more but
then kind of look at the stats it's not
it's not as much as I was expecting
which I kind of feel like I wanted to be
more but at the same time I don't know I
played a fight Mass Effect 2 you know
maybe like six times so but that games
only 30-plus hours so every time you
played it you found something did you
make new decisions and go from renegade
- yeah so I do my first my first run is
always Paragon and then I'll do the
renegade run
I do like female Shepard male Shepard I
do different romances and I did a run
that I completely forgot about why
romance to Jacob and I know Levi until i
heated up Mass Effect 3 and it said you
and import this save and I like doing
that but then I did I did I remember
because Jacob says something like but
the prize when he's fighting with you I
was like oh yeah that that will ever
forever be ingrained in my mind
permanent masks like memory I found zero
Xion they were on outer terminus and
finally I can take the Rosine down yes
all right it is time all right let's see
what they're up to here see I have this
very evil trick up my sleeve where I can
actually sabotage the mission and make
them fail
so if enough people oh no I think
they're Rhino which is like one of the
tank iasts frames in the game which is I
mean advantage them maybe
maybe just cause they've got the tanky
which which will forever be gone I'm the
stalker oh oh we're not even a dream oh
wow this is not a playable character at
all this is the equivalent of leg oh no
oh no oh man the equivalent of like one
of our NPCs that's actually don't go for
their friend Oh in the ranks in the regs
exactly I'm actually gonna cuz there's
Ian ones tryna trying to get into the
one oh don't they have irons going on
which is totally nullifying them from
any damage sources until I break the
iron skin gosh look they thought about
this this is a calculator they got me I
dropped loot look this is actually quite
the magnanimous effort we're doing cuz
I'm dropping loot for them when they'd
kill me I mean this is a Chinese stream
through and through you're dropping loot
anyway that's the way it goes alright
we'll head back to outer terminus on PC
see who's there more squads there are
more squads
so we're Oh target has escaped that's no
good huh oh no women I mean
remember guys we are doing this to raise
money for two great causes for black
lives matter and covered 19 Direct
Relief Reb and I are gonna be donating
for all the wins that she gets so please
donate as well links are on the screen
below and in the description oh these
are innocent bystanders oh I know I'll
just I'll let them kill me and run away
all right okay they can I'll let them
kill me I feel too bad I'll just shoot
their cat there we go there you go they
did it they had their moment maybe I
gave him some loot I did I did I got
some loot all right let's see here I'm
so mo Ali Khan says they fixed it okay
sweet and Leon Torres seven says they
are on mission now in determinist
I think I just made it through to mo Ali
Khan so I think it uh it's gonna go
through sometimes it just takes a second
to establish that stock connection but
typically if I don't see the error
message that says they're not in a
mission it's good we're good Rin Oh
all right boys yeah we're acting here
all right let's see
ninja rific I'm taking you on I'm taking
names
it's like you're gonna be doing your
chore list and you're gonna be like why
do I have to ninja rific here what's
what is this
okay they are in a they're playing as a
mirage Prime one of my favorite
warframes
in a survival mission so I could help
them with this or hinder effect
oh you could you could help them with
the mission and then just at the very
end just ten how to kill them exactly
like a total yeah
like good career that was one of my
favorite things to do in the division
you know when you go into the the docks
okay I see them do I have enough punch
through oh whoa
why are they immune to damage are they
blocking oh oh my gosh I actually think
I just got fooled by their fighter I got
them I got them nice congratulations
you got your bow uh taking all these
names oh okay oh I have it in the in the
chat no oh I imagine that in full Darth
Vader voice totally okay but okay so
we've got don't wipe down the list we've
got not one s in a November oh I'm gonna
see if I can remember the alphabet
November Alfa Romeo
tennis I don't know one yep Sierra
Sierra its own art 1s yes
target not mission 9 mission if you want
it if you want to get invaded in mission
public matchmaking okay in that case
we've got glacial Emperor or just felt
as intended spelled as intended
I actually don't have time for
apparently so glacier glacial or glacial
glacial and poorer got it
targeted mission and and burrow and
barrel and he and he o our yeah I put
that the second time cuz I figured Mason
I looked at it I was like that's not
right and now I know but they're not in
mission so maybe I'll hit two outer
terminus once more at optimal says
they're on earth Cambria
oh that's where new players are though
and actually that's not a node that I
can hit right now so there's no one
there no I'll try it glacial Emperor
again
nope alright let's see analog/digital
just said I'm gonna use tennis let's
redo the reason not to
I'll try oder terminus again just to see
if we have any unfortunate victims yes I
would be the unfortunate soul more
likely than not but Ahnold Alfonso
Contreras says hi space mom hello how's
it going how did you get that nickname
it's so apt I love it's because I've
voiced the very motherly character in
the game hmm
and it just became a moniker that I I
have to embrace rather than rather than
fight alright I don't know I don't know
if these people are in in on the the
joke here so they might be we've got
we've got like fellow Rafa is ready and
then sure if ik pootis man are leon
Torres no one can kill me just in case
they're not in on the joke and I'll feel
bad but I'll give them my loot so it's
all good
I hope it is Bob kids they are in on the
joke this is Dave they got you that oh
man they the messers become the messies
it's true alright what was their last
name you said uh uh so we've got pootis
man ah so
what the hell's P I don't know but I
might know who that is
P oh is @p oot is ma an arc
yeah we're in we're in perfect all right
I'm gonna bring up the phonetic alphabet
oh my gosh we can be like a coordinated
like strike squad this hasn't been my
dream he is okay Oh Lise I just saw
someone die right before my very eyes
and it wasn't me that killed them
so okay they have a cat named citrus 2.0
I would like to know what happened to
citrus 1.0 yeah okay we're in okay we're
gonna get them there they are one of our
speedster Warren Goss which is gonna be
very very hard to land a hit on because
they can travel very very fast oh dear
oh dear oh dear okay I can get them I
can do it I believe in you you got this
oh I don't I don't I don't actually I
gonna go melee just stay right there
ah so for my failure my failure is
documented for all to see older they
were doing a friendly gesture on me can
you go in and just like dance around
them and then like back out I can just
help them you know we can turn this into
like a helping hand but first where's
the fun in them okay mo Ali Khan says
can you guys try me again
I was afk
I'm coming for you it says you're not
mission so get in mission everything
says hi swole mom what's up all right
I'm sorry mo but you're not in mission
so I cannot come to take you on in a
sincere way otama nel is waiting on
Cambria keep putting in the chat but I
don't think Cambria there's one person
on Cambria what do you what was their
name otama nel okay
if that doesn't appear to be the
username I'll let them kill me so that I
don't
we're in some part new players like
zombies yeah okay I'll try this this
wolfram game everyone's talking about
and just immediately get grief I'm just
like oh I'm gonna go they were sincere
they have a cat called catastrophe and
do they want me to help them with the
mission perhaps I don't know help with
any help or hinder oh I wonder if they
were like watching so they can see where
I'm going no that's cheating see if I
can get him this way
stealth Oh visible Oh No Oh are they
using shuriken because that's just an
enemy seeking we have someone else in
the mission ooh someone else has joined
which I couldn't could just pick off oh
no fault - stalker teleport okay
oh this person is very very ninja-like
they're using ash which is invisible and
can throw sure oh I almost had them I
almost had them I swear so close oh no I
think there's some new players spotting
it oh no oh my shields are down oh well
this is usually how it goes you know
usually like a ten to one ratio if ten
kills on me before I go one oh you put
two in you're good um okay we have
someone on Cassini castle Oh Cassini
that's on us so s yn4 Oh for Cassini on
Saturn oh it's not their stock s YN 404
yeah okay I mean easy
alright word word
I should get my sunglasses in just a
pack of loose weight yeah like the sy
and 404 target acquired
all right okay you're in a stalker
cosplay they are dressed like this the
stalker so this is like a true nemesis
mob
this is about what would the I don't
know what kind of like jewel of the
fates type music should we have in this
point
Oh for this showdown this is one of
years of rivalry nemesis so we're gonna
need our own take on okay okay there's
one melee okay okay okay that's okay
we can oh I've killed something oh oh
okay I don't like I don't like the melee
they have that's a very large range
melee weapon which would I think do you
know oh no like I'm helping them
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh see their little
whirlwind spin there this is those those
sweet okay all right oh no you can see
me up
okay I got their shields down mmm-hmm
which is good
Logan in chat uh it's not gonna work on
xbox it's easy own emigrate I think I
think I've been going about this all
wrong
I think stealth is more more beneficial
than mine cuz if they can't see me
they can't I can't kill you because oh
that was good oh he doesn't know so
basically my only option is to get like
a head shot with the bow because I think
the fire rate on my
ah on my throwing knives is let's see oh
it's a throwing knife match Oh No oh
they actually have the full stalker load
oh right now this is how they got fat is
that like it in-game just you know
cosplay thing yeah you can um they got
me and they're proving their point
so basically when I said when I'm
dropping loot they can get the stalkers
weapons if they killed a stalker that's
how we set it up so this is usually this
character is controlled by AI shows up
in your missions and if you kill him you
have a chance to get his gear so players
that have his gear have killed him
enough times and now that's the type of
showdown we had very poetic I've got an
awkward a list of names I feel like
Santa do you want to put in the twitch
chat or if you want to go through the
twitch chat let's see here we have
Travis talking about doodles of fates og
stalker did do smokescreen when is this
coming out Reb why haven't we upgraded
to bhrama if anyone in twitch chat
watching wants me to stalk them they got
to be on PC I just need your username
and we're we're good to go but let's see
if you have one ready now we can we can
try so on Everest oh we've got mix two
two two eight mix two two two eight tilt
see hmm
we'll hit everest up and see who's there
and then I'm Debbie Sheen mom I'm poor
but come get me for charity dad I will
gladly come find you username and I put
their location I think I am with true
new players here so I feel a little bad
so I will I will I will help them rather
than hurt them that's very sweet
wait we're gonna help them and give them
a little bit of a support
moment will help them do this excavator
and then we'll go away Oh someone a
[ __ ] Chad says tell Rebecca this
and see her reaction
Jojo is the most overrated show in
history no I specifically feel that that
is not true because I I can't why would
it be popular I've never seen any Jojo
but I am aware of the memes that's
sometimes all you need that's all I knew
once but now you've ascended cuz even
watch it it's it's a new it's a new
lifestyle
Debbie Sheen so Tyrannis
is the username so ta ra n is and their
envoy and they said Voigt I will shoot
okay they might need to have their
mission to public because it's not
letting me in so make sure at the top
left of your game if you're on PC you
switch to public and head to any mission
that's not real Jack and I can come get
you well on the outs of terminus if you
want to go to Pluto digressive is that
no digressive I'm in coming for you
I feel like you got all the usernames on
YouTube on Twitch there's a people are
asking what's going on but there's no
usernames drop you'll yeah
dropping usernames in chat either on
Twitter on YouTube making a list and
rabble come get you okay here we go
I see digress I'm okay I'm gonna go for
the stealth angle this time though this
is my sis my plan if we go sneaky
calculated if I can just get one
headshot with my bow
I think it's game over game over man
game over
just again the other day yeah all right
let's see here can I do it can it be
done I'm banana can I achieve such feats
the answer will uh probably you know but
they are knocked down thanks to the
robotic oh no they found me okay I gotta
plan my escape here one time we did this
on a stream and our creative director
Steve got a head shot from like four
hundred meters away and ever since then
he's refused to play it cuz like it was
the most skilled moment I was gonna say
that's I'm just gonna retire from
everything now this is me done sit this
is it that was his last gameplay I think
he ever did here digressive is running
away because they are going with the
evasion while I was trying to do stealth
but I think I can add insult to injury
and take out their companion actually
don't that someone else's companion oh
come on
oh no oh oh no you go there we go okay I
got the dog the hitch on that dog set
for sweet sweet dog
wait until this duel is over and then a
couple in the chat are asking what's
going on oh okay
this duel is between me and a willing
participant that has allowed me the joy
of invading their fame to try take a
mouse
so I'll Killa if you want to take part
if you're planning on PC drop your
username in the chat make sure you've
got public matchmaking or go to Pluto is
it out of terminus friend that we're
going that's where we're good oh that's
where we're gonna be going oh okay Max
is down what are you gonna do are you
gonna let your you know let your opinion
bleed out what's your what's your plan
here be pretty mean digresses don't you
think oh okay they're doing the ground
slam approach which I have infinite ammo
which is great oh no oh no oh oh I died
but so did their companion so who's the
real winner um all right what have we
got
Oh so our killer now that they know
what's going on they put their IGN in so
ow ow killer Oh wo W killer
I'll kill her you're not in mission
mm-hmm
get in mission okay in that case don't
ride Taranis again not in mission as
well Debbie come on Debbie she's a fan
artists entire community she's amazing
our killer says logging into a mission
right now okay digressive says Gigi Reb
an eye for an eye Oh max the dog for my
life I understand it makes sense we've
got a couple of donations in I'm gonna
read so where are we
25 bucks from Alessandra filari he hit
me up early and he was like I put 400
hours into Wolfram at this point
definitely gonna be tuning in and
watching and donation so thank you very
much and from the 70s $5 to
blacklivesmatter thank you very much
donation links out on the screen we're
raising money for two very good causes
link is also in the description below
every little help all free let's see all
right Wow killer nor taranis are in a
public mission and if you are I I don't
mean to say that you aren't but right
now it's not detecting that you're in
one so gosh maybe in there and saying
I'm doing everything right and it's not
working but Alice door forgive us mother
stop killing your poor children it's
merely a charity endeavor there's no
there's there's no killing here our
Achilles says which node should I go to
if they just want to head to outer
terminus on Pluto that works very well
they could go there
there's other yeah I think that's a good
spot yeah I think there are other people
that too okay all had cut their down see
what happens okay moment of truth
someone and twitch chat says I need to
find a guide for the new stuff since
2014 we've added two open worlds a whole
space simulator thing you know I was on
that way alright
Oh someone's playing our new warframe
here I think I think this person doesn't
know so I feel bad kill me what's thy
using him like an eyebrow
Rory are aw are auw are why they're not
on my list
yeah I'll let them I'll let them kill me
I'll just shoot at nothing although I
look like he gave new trail effects to
the stalker spell Digital Extremes for
now what was stood nine and a half years
oh yeah
so I'm oh um yeah so I'm I started in
January 2011 so nine and a half years
exactly almost oh I was gonna say like
given the Jenny the Wolfram as a game
has had and also the studio's had what
I've been like would have been your
highlights do you think if you if you
have to sort of look back and reflect on
your time there it's kind of depressing
because Tenno Khan is always the
highlight and this year not only do we
not get to have a physical one for a
very good reason but we moved it it was
supposed to be the Saturday but now it's
August first so it's like there's no
usual Tenno Khan which would have been
our fifth one so the highlights have
always been that event so it's a very
different year because we don't get that
same swell of in person like oh right
our game is played by people whose lives
have been impacted by it in it
yeah so you know Oh sad that it's gone
but we'll do it digitally it'll be fine
we're doing this digitally it'll all
work out I think I think as well and
it's like it's weird cause - it's like
everyone's kind of at home there's no
III there's no packs there's no Tennant
con but I don't know
I think everyone's making the right
decision and being safe and counseling
those kind of events and moving them
online and you know oh yeah I mean we
started everything online that's kind of
all we do right it's our bread and
butter so all right let's see if these
people know I'm coming because I'm a
little worried they don't okay it's your
friend I'll kill it
um so glacial Emperor says I just saw
you attack Laurie oh I was in their
mission yeah right - all right okay I am
in the mission without killer finally so
we can take them down they're using
Valkyr who is a very tanky frame so I'm
not really sure how I feel about this
choice but if I am just stealthy enough
which I will be mocked for saying as I
do very unselfie oh wait someone's
playing the guitar wait what oh they
were chosen anyway okay well now we know
how many shots in the head it'll take I
think defenses are being buffed by
Garrett I'm gonna say wait one second
didn't you just say like gum
yeah just blowing you this one headshot
that was a lie damn it I don't think
I'll get any kills anymore I should say
last year we added um guitar playing to
the game is just kind of like a fun
little thing and you can do it the
mission so everyone can just robot go
just have a little little sing-along
come by Oh exactly we can play our own
you know our own beats and jams
um okay so who do we have that did we
find fun ow ow okay um what about where
are you at ten
mister freezer with three e's is on at
ten
three e's mr. freezer target none so
like MRF reee said er yes not mission
mission okay
king of nightmare whoo okay
king of nightmare
target on mission hmm let's see
Oh if we want to go out to Pluto khonshu
moon is there on outer terminus
abstemious yeah here we go
I love outer tournament I love saying
outer terminus it sounds very mass
effect actually it really does it's got
a good I was gonna say good mouthfeel
out to terminus like it's a great it's a
great region
everyone loves outer terminus because of
the mouthfeel all right here we go
we have mu - you disgust fire 6 and
cherry maka here those know they know
what they know it's me they so mean
don't you think that hi mom okay they
know it's okay okay let's see we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna get a bit
more tact earlier I mean you've been a
participant so far in my approach do you
have any tips for as an overwatch player
what am I doing wrong in this PvP world
um
well so I mean Stoica here is basically
a mix between gangi and Hanzo in terms
of movement
you got the bow - very hands oh the
movement very Genji like two characters
I don't play us so great after a great
start great start I think I think just
like pick them off and keep running
around picking them off don't let
yourself get into any situations we
don't have an escape route there you go
oh oh I got I got a height when I'm on
fire I have to run away that is just uh
that is a life lesson I mean I think
that's just good for everyone
see the problem is I was just taking
down a Garuda who has an ability to just
generate their own health fool so case
may be good for them yeah go them first
okay where did that yeah take out the
take out the helos
it was going so well I did it I did it I
did it what you did it
alright scream boy there I thought you
were screaming with like no I'm sorry
okay we're in so that's it's up three
wins now here's a full that would've
been my third did alright doesn't count
I mean else I'll put a point five don't
very good analog/digital says always
have an exit strategy there we go I love
I like a lot of people have made
warframe overwatch crossover fashion
with with one of our frames that kind of
looks the most like Genji so that's
funny that you say that because that's a
very common thing um Indian Waldo okay
postman says yeah thanks for the invade
read there you go okay okay right you're
in we are ready to go here
oh we've got a few more donations too
but I'll read them after this after this
would you call it invasion
okay so I see them they are using mega
who is a warframe that has great
defensive abilities so this is there are
you know a little little on the tanky
side so hopefully I can see if they
don't see me what could possibly go
wrong
Oh God they see me okay it's all over
[Music]
okay they have a very high range melee
weapon I think I can see they have a hit
get can also fire projectiles depending
on how they set it up which oh it's a
guerra that's very bad for me very bad
indeed she can create basically an
unlimited amount of maze ice walls with
her class well not you bring the this
sort of like the overwatch comparison
like yes yeah you know it's that's a
hero shooter this is just a hero game
you'd be surprised
yeah the parallels it's here
let's see Mitch says thanks for
listening to my song Rab oh sorry for
trying to kill you while you're playing
good okay
I'm making a new list uh okay so
Mohammed says if a play has completed
the objective she can't invade their
session that right yeah okay so public
matchmaking public server but don't
complete the objective yeah so just wait
it's this wait for me okay they are
trying to kill me with their operator
which is a little bit of a that would be
a flex I think the cool kids say now
there's actually two people in this
mission that I've already encountered so
we have a bit of a yeah
people are getting wise to my scheme
here and following them the people were
stalking so now it's like a three on one
but I think you're doing a very good job
evading darting around got the exit
strategy the exit strategy advice is
probably the most very very helpful
I caught take credit for that that was
different from the job
[Music]
okay
ah be the AOS were too stronk they got
you oh ok so if we want to on Pluto
khonshu moon khonshu moon on Pluto
we will head back to outer terminus and
see what see what type of action we get
on the outer the outer terminus node
also on ask terminus if we run into them
is fellow ruff ruff oh we're back again
so yeah kunchu kunchu moon is waiting
okay that one actually didn't go through
because I had already been defeated by
that party so not a mission mm-hmm we
will try yes again
let me read out some donations where
we're trying so for black lives matter
20 bucks from Leonard um a morale thank
you so much 25 baht 25 dollars from John
Wesley thank you and Mike Galvin was
digressive I believe is $10 to lives
matter thank you so much thank you all
yes and donation links on the screen
every little helps please give what you
can
ok so
[ __ ] you country moon on Pluto out to
terminus waiting in for your stalker
Nikki yeah we'll see if it's them yeah
knave are they taking names from here
yes I I've got a list and checking it
twice so I gosh we got Debbie Sheen huh
go Debbie Debbie is here Debbie going
down okay
okay here we go this is this was my
chance this is a spicy
Oh God like I got her hey I got her I
got you I got you Debbie well done well
done
she was standing still I have to admit I
was but at the same time a win is a win
a witness a win is a win
okay so uh if khonshu moon isn't there
did we find mr. freezer there on Adam
let's see stock mr. freeze are not in
mission Aten ah which that's not really
that's not a meta known so I'm not
really how do you spell it
a TEM I know everything about this game
used item well we can move on to God's
child gaming no location okay let's see
God's child gaming yeah
target not mission I'm afraid well I'm
not afraid I'm afraid for you because
that could have been your moment to show
your worth and we have oh wait so two
people on out to terminus we've got
fellow Roth and conga 36 I'm coming for
you I will say that no one in twitch
chat has given their names yet otherwise
I would be adding to the to the list but
I think they all made it to YouTube so
yeah YouTube is action is in the void oh
[Music]
let's try a deterministic acquiring
targets in outer terminus and we have
succeeded nice
okay so who we tracking here this is our
killer again they actually have a
companion named Lake uh that reminds me
of Lake estudios with their awesome
stop-motion scene um Oh what was that
second one cuz they did Coraline right
and they get Kubo and the two strings
subo so good I really want to see that
actually the guitar we put in the game
is very similar to the the two strings
guitar all right let's see how a killer
what are they using as a warframe this
will determine my if I thought there you
think about here again okay bad for me
bad for me not off to a good start off
to a very bad start first oh and they
copy it's great
this is the real grudge match it's you
versus our killer so we've not wrong not
wrong if we got out to Tim as you can
try fella off why no fellow off
there is a small chick I'm not worried
we got feller off he fell off I don't
want to misspeak I think they're from I
want to see Italy but I might be
misremembering the name
might be misremembering
oh I feel it says come back some more
give me those blueprints they just want
to fire me I knew it I knew up I could
tell listen sin is like it is mine I
named her after the dog the Russians
sent into space
oh I found fella off they are using
nesha as well very tanky warframe which
is very very bad for me yet again but I
can be a little bit stealthy you know
and just I might try my best
oh they are with king of nightmare as
well which one other yeah yeah another
name I am taking taking your name's
pixel 17 got yours
our killer says they'll use a different
frame next time oh is that a rematch
think that's like I was gonna say the
final jewel jewel of the fates do all
the faith's retro I I've got oh they got
me
ah can we got me for 4/10 ok ok that's
ok so glacial Emperor mix 2 2 2 8 and
Candy Man criminal all waiting for you
um where are you
I've got your new list on my list I
think mix they're on Tyrannis Hey where
the heck is Taranis I thought it was in
the void yep ok here we go I'm going
into Tyrannis ok alright so there's this
three of them waiting for ya well well
well
wouldn't it be a shame if all three of
them died by my hand this is just a
board dude Oh No well then I'll mix two
two two eight it's one of them okay I'll
get the next time just meanwhile I'll
just help this poor soul oh they're a
very strategic player this one they're
using a very good defensive warframe for
a defense mission so kill me kill me
I feel bad kill me kill me get the stuff
Oh someone's I think someone's here
helping them now okay good they have
help they have help who's help kill me
Indian Waldo is here oh thank you mundo
well I hope who knows what's going on
because they've asked to be invaded so
they are they are wise to my scheme but
maybe I can take them out without the
guilt
that's so dated oh they got me
okay I feel good about losing that one
given the circumstances yeah let's try
and find mix tandyman criminal and
glacial emperor so raychel Emperor is a
great great name let's see if I can
stock Candyman ring yeah all right let's
get to work Lucy I mean I'm not really
doing anything I'm just I'm singing list
I'm here for emotional and moral support
and too badly recount the phonetic
alphabet to you tennis is a great letter
T word I think it was good on the spot
thinking thank you it's also because I
was just thinking about tennis the other
day miss it weed stuff with Djokovic
going on yes yes what kind of scandals
all right
oh they're all there kneeling and
waiting lawyers waiting
they're literally sitting on the ground
waiting Wow okay that's motivating for a
war all right let's see who will I Oh
one of them has a
wait one of them wants to play something
special okay I can't actually type to
them so they just need to be watching
okay let's see here oh they killed me
before I could play it it's what I died
okay well that one doesn't count that
doesn't count you killed me you lured me
into a false sense of security and time
and then ambushed what what do you make
of that that's an example it's unfair
you wanna try battling them again or
14 the chat says wow they were just
chillin like Thanos totally just you
know in in their post snap world
Okami okay first of all I am a huge fan
of a commie Amaterasu in chat who's
clearly a big fan of the plot well
clovis to do is classic and one of my
favorite games of all time cuz that
wolfram name is a commie sure enemy
which is also one of the names from the
game so I actually can't I can't restock
the same mission twice I mean the game
rules prevent me from doing so so
they'll have to reform their Lobby for
me to join it but in the meantime you
can I can go akame what was that he so
okami under school shirani we Shi are a
n UI
all right I think that worked that's no
kinetic
ooh okay Lord fat-cat will put you on
next they've said join Lord fat cat on
outer terminus we can have a stalker
versus shadow stalker
showdown I like the sounds of that I
like this okay we are
oh you're kneeling Oh ready they're
dressed as the stalker as you can see
there they are in full full cosplay we
would we would say I think we would call
it that fellow Rob says you are correct
they are from Italy there you go so here
we go look at us twins look at this look
at us we thought who'd have thought can
I get a screen shot sure I'll stay still
there we go nice all right let's see
yeah did they get their screen shot I
don't know
oh they're sentinels attacking me see
there's a little more to see if we can
kill their robot how much help does it
have oh it probably has some regen on it
so it's preventing it from dying so if
any uh if any warframe players wanted to
be on the receiving end of a sentinel
attack this is what it looks like and
yes I don't think we're gonna get the
screenshot but I will shoot you in the
head see it's even one headshot isn't
enough gone yeah so I need to land
several shots it's not about the the
journey it's about the destination of
victory now there's a port do player
here who I will try not to kill a little
in the splash zone like they literally
have the starter gear so I will do my
best to save them from this oh no I
don't want to hurt anyone except Okami I
think that new player left actually
I just like like grandpa Simpson gif so
they have Matt okay I got their shields
down or partial shield down now see here
I am on fire which is not good for
surviving unless it's you know to do
with your skills and you're like I'm on
fire how you choose to look at the world
okay they are taking oh shoot
someone in twitch ad travesty spirit of
hydrops I used to be on cap cons mailing
list I'll see if I have any okami swag
still oh swag is the greatest tempter
temptation of all sorry nothing to do
with the economy because I feel like
Capcom really like that like I think all
the cool stuff they could make with it
I'm otaku so cute
nothing bunch of statues like that 1/8
figure ones that early yeah okay so
we've got um Lord fat cat oh right
great name I was gonna not admission get
yourself in mission okay well Philip is
in the outs of terminus Philip with one
L ph IL IP not a mission so one thing
that we did wanted to clarify is that if
you complete the mission objective I
can't stalk you so you need to be just
chillin not doing the mission playing
guitar
if you want it okay so I'll put a star
next to them get in mission a snooty Fox
prime I'm typing target not mission
okay Steve emission read underscore
terror is in ISM Venus ish talk call me
with your terror is not in mission but
we can head to Ishtar but it's such a
new player level that I think doing the
blind stalk could have a very confused
new player but we can we can see what
happens let's go visit Ishtar hmm
we can actually look at the we just
updated this map brand new branding
Sparkle and stuff whoo yeah think we we
can do a interior review with stalker so
it's like half battling players half
creeps in groups its cribs are these
real do they know
do you recognize the name just a target
or a neutronic know as a little red
underscore Tara was there um king of
nightmare was there but I think they
moved okay let's see these people on me
okay so they are they are not wise to
this game so we will just behave like an
AI
so that means miss a lot Wow the one
person I wanted to miss I hit but
they're alive still so it's okay okay
morning flare I've got you
Craig to 2k let's do you next you've
been waiting for a while okay they
killed me and they took my loot we did
it it was a good karma moment I didn't
try
[Music]
okay so Craig to 2k Craig where where
are you come from stock Craig to - okay
yeah I think we're in I think Ramona I
think we got him yes we are in this
versus Craig we'll see what happens
I wanted to do big so like Call of Duty
like we'll get next time oh we have a
four-person squad here this is this is
not good for me
I'm gonna hide I'm gonna use stealth to
my advantage here this is nice this is
my plan okay I like it a lot
strike from the shadows hopefully
they're not also watching well we know
they are watching the stream and hoping
they're not using that to get your
location okay I got a wisp I hit with
with my Oda god oh god oh god wisp can
regenerate health on on a time you know
they can passively regenerate health
depending on how they've built their
warframe don't you know I deal in my
crotch invasion situation but no in the
context of the regular game a lot of fun
great fun I'm also playing against an
immortal warframe here which is very
very difficult to kill you'll find
gotcha I mean yeah clues if losing the
name basically can't be killed so that's
unfortunate for sure a lot of reasons
for me
I think my stealth angle is actually so
far proving successful they don't know
where I am
which is great if I can just evade fast
enough they lose track of me so I think
yeah I think this is the strike from the
shadows striking the shadows have an
escape plan strike from the shadow oh no
they found me we were going over the
escape on one must use the escape plan
not just have one all right let's see
here
let's see these fools fall for my my
situation yes yes yes Lucy that would be
a victory on a rebecca column they wind
up to five snooty Fox prime says they
fixed it so let's go sneaky Fox prime
again another excellent username Emery's
lovely I can verify that their fix
worked
alright alright
oh this is um I think this is a a group
that we've already fought like mo Ali
Khan doesn't this one so I think I think
there's gonna be a little bit of
conspiracy here if I may be so bold wait
if they're watching the stream they know
they know your strats now I don't know
my escape plan okay I'll have all the
corners covered the shadows each and
every shadow will be brought into the
light okay I've I'm gonna keep that
strategy going it worked last time this
mission we're fighting in inaros a
Wukong and a mirage inaros is also
basically immortal gotcha so Mirage is
really my only option here I'm here to
kill but Mirage is really fast and
evasive so I don't know Lucy I don't
know about this one I believe in you
thank you I think it's good the strats
failed to prepare her to fail what's the
thing right yeah yeah okay inaros is
essentially a god so that's a bad for me
yeah oh they got me
Oh No escape plan okay see if this is a
dead end I managed spotted trouble
yeah I don't think they can see me I
don't think they know where I went okay
well I don't like digital reckons you're
getting stream Snipes so oh really yeah
alright you just keep on keep on moving
well if I move fast enough afar they
they won't find me if I go in these bunk
beds which if they're watching they'll
know exactly where I am but I just
come in come through the doors come
welcome in okay here we go
that's good that's what you want to see
you want to see these those damage
numbers okay inaros is taking three
damage wow they found me okay redirect
oh I know where to go okay
do we reckon they're straight I don't
know I think I think this one is
innocent
I agree so the punch through should
allow to uh they found me
oh they found me Oh hamburgers Oh
hamburgers
how big is is a great like not swear
word but with the same meaning of so
swollen it's perfect
did they get you yeah they know Ali Khan
is very happy they're saying all caps
get her know and now I'm gone I mean it
was a strategy there they had one to DES
was just to be attacking you again they
do they knew what to do
doth Bob fourteen kept it in the void
Darth Bob fourteen and the void is a
great place to it's not open as an
option if you finished the mission
objective I can't actually hunt you uh
uh Hamid says revenge is sweet meat
snooty Fox prime my bodyguard in my clan
thanks mate Wow okay so they now have
some mythos in their clan of the time
that's that's good that's good okay Jay
net in valise J a Y and a tea
oh that's actually a really we can go
visit an open world I didn't even go
there in the valise so now the trick is
oh it's not unlocked shoot plains of
Eidolon is though so we could go I want
to go someone is that a chaos painter is
in plains of Eidolon doc chaos painter
yeah oh I think it worked
lovely all right in we go
[Music]
right Terra I think we tried you earlier
we'll try you again let me note bread
underscore Terra
Ishtar yeah we we went to each trucks I
made the joke oh we can just continue on
that comedy streak that's why I'm here
big thank you to Travis sure who donated
to both causes and said thank you to
GameSpot warframe Lucy and Reb for
continuing to do charity streams it's
much appreciated in all my time
following games I've never known anyone
quite like Reb she's such a wonderful
person and the absolute best
representative any fan could hope for
love you space mom kill your brethren
this is too much it's with the emotions
Oh sweetheart and to that end I'm in an
open world now which means there is no
shortage of hiding spots for me yeah so
chaos painter is out here noise and
chaos and I too shall cause chaos rope
code what was your user name retro I you
are on the list it will come to you next
Oh people are invading this mission oh
they're in they know they know oh it's a
hildren that'll be interesting shield
gating will only take you so far my dear
BAM
alright I hear a once an AoE bow that is
troublesome for me oh dear
okay I hit him with the bleed proc nice
now the Rhino in facing has god mode
basically so I have to be very
calculating
I think I got him
they're down but they're not out because
see here
chaos painter is uh-oh this person is
actually trying to play a real mission
oh but kay-kay chaos need your nose nose
what's up so we're having it yeah we're
having a war here this actually this
open world was the oh my gosh can I fly
a vehicle I've never I just got so
excited the thought of flying vehicle
okay hold on if I can go for a drive
this could change the change the outcome
of my let my luck here get in loser will
go in stalking plea if I can find a
vehicle this could be a very very
different stream so we have two methods
of acquiring a vehicle mm-hmm we can
find one organically or we can hijack
one since the sky so I have to find one
first this could be a very different
hunt
oh there's two in the sky there okay if
we can take out a guy on the vehicle
it'll fall to the ground and then I can
pilot it so that's what we want the
trick is not destroying the vehicle and
I'm using a pretty check dial about a
hit scan so we want to
oh they blew it up Oh what just so you
couldn't get it OH
chaos pain here help me out wait oh no
you not to care of pain to dance I'm
counting that oh well do you want count
that as a win is that we got to actually
get him okay I think they're playing
game now so they know to find Dargan
okay this is chaos painter they are now
my friend and we will we will search the
plains for a vehicle once oak says go
north of the great lake go north of the
great lake yeah
okay laughs I've even map it works okay
house painter says in chat let's find
you a vehicle oh um chaos painter if
you're listening I can actually see your
Waypoint so if you find one by all means
drop a waypoint okay North Lake it's
actually raining out here I think do you
hear rain I don't have you a game audio
so right oh great sorry Oh voice of God
there are some god oh we have a waypoint
I will warn you there is a chance this
will crash but I'm willing to take these
risks in life you know you don't you
don't last 10 years in the games
industry without okay with that uh yeah
I can't fly it
what oh I can fly it and it's it's
bugged so if they need to kill me
immediately
oh okay there we go
i bugged out all right let's go that
would that would be great though but I
tried at least being says Lucy doesn't
have revs game audio cuz she's listening
to the economy soundtrack
I mean Capcom did actually put it on
Spotify which was a very very pleasant
for me it's a lovely sounds dope yeah
it's a lovely sound try to work - okay
so I've got a list in order retro I is
sou' Sao on Neptune okay let's let's try
it there we'll go to Neptune
alright there is someone active on
Neptune there so whether or not it is
our target is to be determined yeah it's
them perfect inaudible oh yeah retro I
um sorry I was gonna say we've got a big
fifty dollar donation from Andrew
horrace two black guys man thank you so
much
much love okay here we go retro I is
Goss as well again a very fast character
so bad news for me you're you're very
speedy though and like if it keeps its
tracks safe escape plan okay they are
warning their squad mate of what's gonna
happen oh no which is good but can i oh
gosh they spotted be ready escape plan
escape plan tumble tumble away tumble
away oh gosh please don't find me I
think I think there do you know I'm so
you just kind of like whisper in a game
you even take oh hey can you hear me
okay they are oh I can get candy okay
what are we facing near Meg Goss and oh
there's a versa uhmm I just get cool
300,000 damage on it no biggie oh they
found me a plan will they know I'm in
here
I don't think so look I like this I like
this hide-and-seek angle please feel
like the purpose tool oh god they got me
Oh
uh okay
we've got rope code Ariel on Uranus but
it's uh opie CEO Adi OPC Ord Oh Terry
not mission but we will try and go to
Ariel anyway no I can't
nothing there our OPC Ord
travesty spoon they found me Marty I
don't know how but they found me
scat okay bro code will come back to you
I've made a bullet note jaynette is on
valise je a Y and a tee
NIT NIT ona T sorry
JY n 80 oh I think it works nice oh no
ballast is actually I was foolish
there's or valise which is Venus but
valise is actually a real note if I'm
recalling correctly now and I forget
where it is valise is a real note but
now I can't remember for the life of me
where valise is I said I could just look
around until I see that people will
probably know X I can't actually go to
the orb ballast I can do that for next
time
if we want to hold on wrote code sets
that are restarting the mission
Oh ROP Co Rd yes okay I will hold steady
on them and see ya public server don't
complete the mission right and PC unless
but hopefully they know that we can try
umm Winchester 910 it's a great name
they're on Ishtar again I think we're
good for Winchester sweets well does it
go to Winchester let it all blow over
oh man my friends are gonna do a rewatch
of all those movies oh wait hang on I am
on the Ovilus prohibited region so Jana
if you want to go somewhere else let me
know
I'm grad terror as well by the way
Oh who's with Tara the Red Terror is
here with Winchester nine one zero and
king of nightmare and feather off thanks
okay I need to start a new page of names
[Music]
to add everyone in so very good oh my
gosh one of them has theirs Vauban let's
see beau bond measure Excalibur Umbra oh
gosh they have a cursed cursed fashioned
frame here this is this is horrifying
they must die for this look and killed
him I will
David candy cane crazy his Russian
everything where no no shade to Megan no
she was that win that was win
yep
had to restart so holds you this is a
great one uh 1v1 pacifist uh where is it
Cetus planes okay so they're out on the
open world okay so he lo lotion elo s
tion yellow s tion yes
fingers crossed yes we're in ice
okay Jana has moved to Jupiter call me
okay the next
[Music]
here we go so God's child gaming
go child we've had to you before but
I'll put you on the list
- yeah rustling okay I know where these
people are I will find them all each and
every one big John wick Grimes
oh no wait no taken taken taken rub
cords um we'll come to you next if
you're still in the same spot which was
Ariel okay all right we are in we are in
the open oh it's nighttime now oh wow oh
my gosh 1v1 pacifist so they're playing
as Baruch who is like our pacifist a
monk frame mm-hmm and as you can see
they're posing like like they don't want
to have this fight you know that I've
spawned right in front of it very
peaceful stay out in the open wounds
enjoying sights and scenes and now there
they've essentially lured me and to be
the villain what would you do I don't
know like maybe play play some music for
them just really let them have their
have there's any moment the only way out
is to kill them so this is like one of
those like moral paradoxes this is a
real catch-22 oh wait they say in this
fight we determine who is the backs of
pass offense
oh no oh they're gone okay that was very
Poochie has gone back to his own planet
yeah this is this is a this is a moral
paradox like I don't know what to do if
I attack first then I am I'm the villain
oh my gosh they're playing us a song
oh no anyway he's wonderful anyway okay
I can't kill them they have their allude
up which is evasive pacifist ability so
all projectiles go through with them oh
there's so there's like a lesson here in
life this I feel like we've really
stumbled onto something here this is uh
I actually can't hurt them I could hurt
their cat and not all reveal their
true nature will they save their cat I
selected give them an honorable death
Oh mother rocky no you can't hear it
Lucy but I swear they're playing music
but will they do can you mail a them or
is it just for it's all oh yeah all
sources of damage they they go ethereal
so you can kind of see the em the blue
effect yeah yeah I can't hurt them but
their energy will eventually run out
which is the only it's on a meter so
they're once their energy runs out they
they won't be immortal anymore but
postman says got to try slam damage also
I can't believe I haven't said
experienced tranquility I know
totally totally oh they're they're
invincible again oh oh wait hang on
Mohammed which party in the dojo they're
putting up a banner I need to know she's
coming on up I need to know what to
write on the banner I can't come to
dojos with this particular mode I can if
I switch to my real account but not not
in this fun mode but not in this mode
rope codes real the two options for the
banner a we killed Rebecca
will be welcome Rebecca this is the
duality of man Rob Court it's our OPC
Ord yes
Arielle they are not in a mission they
said they won the you scroll up a bit I
hope it works this time out on the cool
starting tile I'm afraid nothing yet we
can try
a can Tia aka NTIA there on Rosalind
Uranus see nothing there weird
we can try Giga notice Gi ga
n ot us they on Adaro the phonemes as my
handwriting is atrocious
alright we'll go to add our go and see
what we can find and if it is an enemy
or a friend we will know very soon
Oh Jana yes you are Jupiter will come to
you after we will visit the gas city
itself so we'll do Jupiter next got it
yes
call me now you have to make sure you
don't have the mission objective
completed otherwise and you get to make
sure you're on public so public no
mission complete
I'm let's see here I don't know if these
people are in on the joke or not
Alex of all i vas imperative all mmm
recognized um all right I'll let them
kill me
can she says um we that it didn't work
for me I'm on public status and I'm not
touched the objective okay we'll try
again after and then pokémon champion
dark Bob fourteen you are still on the
list alright well so it's very weird to
me that your YouTube user name is Greg
Miller well I can hear him in the other
room I don't think he's playing warframe
excuse me sir Greg waited all right um
so we're trying Jupiter at present time
yes so who's on Jupiter J net I don't
actually see there I know the node
they're on but I don't actually see it
so let's see here J a yn 80 okay we're
good all right
you
we have people in chat just saying I'm
not very good at stalker mode but that's
fine that's cool I'm um I'm not here to
flex I'm here to get destroyed well Greg
is tweeting me about something not
related to warframe streaming back as
well from pinions oh there we go we have
a Jaina it's actually riding one of our
ambient room buds that we have in game
my system seen here this is an ambient
rumba battle and I think they want us to
to demonstrate hey oh they're playing
Zephyr which is gonna be very
problematic for me because I I cannot
get through their turbulence but if I
ride the drone Oh
ambient rumba by the way is a fantastic
using ambient rumba I'm being free for
all J not you killed me I was trying to
ride the Roomba and you went out there
and did me like that well do you want to
UConn cuz it's the same session right
I'm gonna go out I'm gonna count that as
a win for the community there we can try
Darth Bob 14 mantle Darth Bob 14 I think
we tried to get off Bob oh yeah we did
try they are not in a mission according
to the I will just try going to mantle
directly though because you never know
what brute force can achieve
analog-digital says Reb dying at the
hands of warframe community players and
dropping loot for them is the ultimate
flex if there we go
I found Darth Bob nice Oh Jaina it says
I didn't realize you trying to ride the
node I'm so sorry
oh they are in their own glass enclosure
here I see that they have they're
meditating before the battle this is
like the art of war
oh isn't that how to win it's like
prepare
welcome to pokemon stadium can you
defeat my Pokemon oh that makes sense
cuz in the YouTube chat they said
Pokemon master dark Bob oh I see I see I
think I can't actually Darth Bob I think
you might have underestimated my skill
or overestimated my skill cuz now I will
embarrassingly lateness oh my god Thank
You graduation Romans thank you it's
been a it's been a long journey uh we
can try star boost under school
thirty-six star boost underscore
thirty-six I picked it in i've hit enter
not in mission in mission malkia mal que
i you are Malky ur not mission you gotta
have public matchmaking and don't finish
the objective yet postman says Reb is
the ultimate pokemon player she attacks
the trainer it's not the focus see this
is the type of high IQ thinking that a
Pokemon master should have did you get
any note names because I'm a week I can
just visit those drop your note names in
we have if you want to get some revenge
Ataman L is waiting on Cambria earth
will show you something funny real
immortal warframe oh are you intrigued
like I am I'm intrigued
FC your buff we we are we're going to
see what this immortal warframe action
is series it's limbo there we go
oh but there's a new player with them um
I - man no must know that there we must
help this new player there's a new
player with them we can't we cannot okay
this is weak vessel there's an ethical
mission now we have to aid in this new
players journey out of an old your eye I
get it you're limbo you're immortal but
we can't let this poor
new player lose due to our hubris little
17 where are you and Jane Jana would
like a rematch this time a fair rematch
they are lure Grimaldi so I mean we'll
go pixel 17 you first and then we'll go
to you Jana actually have to abort the
mission I got stuck in my craw no I'm
sorry some I mean that was the first
issue rather than the flying one so not
so bad something is happening here
something new and mysterious oh this
might be the real fun now I might have
been in some weird mode before
hoorah she what is your uh your pixel
seventeen and you would like a
screenshot with Rebecca oh okay once we
get that yes the new player dying we'll
just have to be a casualty of war frame
no stand for such things
um where to next pixel underscore
seventeen
all right
but they are going they would like a
screen shot with you fist okay okay we
can pull that off that's that's no
problem
I'm I'm for one curious what their
loadout is oh sure they commented some
people have been comments in what
they've been what they've got what
they're working with but I don't think
pixel has yeah pixel is using NYX prime
who is our psychic
oh hello rubs thank you for the great
game oh joy on the monday all right
we're gonna get a screenshot together
look at that pretty smoke that's right
like can i switch camera sides i can
look at us together for being invaded by
others Oh an ice cream jar
I think everyone's trying to get in so
we can oh you know what we are in a
scenario that will allow us to ride a
Roomba Oh
hopefully I'm no one will attack it we
could only hope the quest for the Roomba
has begun they should be scattering
about the ground c'est la vie here we go
we found one malkia we think back on the
list so we'll go Jane at mix malkia and
then okay alright because we are running
out of time and what you're gonna go
about 15 minutes left let's try and get
through as many as possible
this person has renamed their secondary
weapon Lotus there you go oh that's
that's the real space mom now I feel bad
killing this person this is like some
type of like emotional you know oh I'll
get you hah strings I know I don't want
to hurt them now Candyman you're going
down there yeah Candyman you doomed
Candy Man is actually an infamous player
at one point in time generated a lich so
in warframe we have this lit system
where you generate a threat that's
unique to your account and there Lich's
name was so hilarious I laughed until I
cried and they to this day they haunt me
with their Lich
it was a cold bop bip so it uses like a
random name generator and it was it was
game over for me at that point in time
um J net okay you're on Lua
oh right Grimaldi's remotely Oh
someone's username is chicken tacos
truly I could really go for some um
regretfully I can't go to Lua because I
have not the stalker has not completed
the quest chain that unlocks the lure
region so I am I am I'm unable to go in
China uh head to outer terminus I guess
we'll come back to you hmm okay
Oh mix two two two eight whoo I think we
have the fall is a on Maas offal
confirmed and we go we can go to this
sandy Red Planet hmm bump it shall live
forever there you go that's a threat oh
I think it's a new player oh it is I can
help them I can do this by mission for
them all right we'll just uh just play
it play it simple well let them kill me
I know
no I feel bad kill me kill me kill me
I'm gonna try to make a lot of noise so
that they kill me okay thinking about it
not really no no maybe they maybe they
didn't know what was going on I got a
little scared I'm sorry
oh great primary responsibility that's
true
we've got malkia and ALK i you are
alright malc here i'm coming for you and
then we'll do J next they're moving to
the opposite semanas oh that's gonna be
your rematch is it not hi Jana yeah yeah
Jana well I mean they said this one's
gonna be a fair fight okay okay there's
last time what they just blew up the
they did okay all right Malky er has an
unmodified so I will switch to my melee
weapon as well yes we will engage in a
sparring match let's see here unmod in
prison is Ghana
I have a very Oh mean is down I have
killed their companion but not them
Estevan chat fish meat meat sorry bud oh
I got out here nice skin retentions GG
one more in the column okay jayna out to
terminus alright this time it'll be fair
okay Brooke cold I've written you down
too
Jaina is ready to be stalked and I am
loading in right now perfect
all right a fair fight this time please
yes no funny business
there's two people waiting for me in
this room mr. creeper and Jane at this
is another body God situation another I
don't know this one looks a bit more
organic I think these people have all
just come to outer terminus to prepare
for this reckoning they're there in the
crowd they've got the music going
they're ready all right they said good
luck to each other oh okay let's see
here we could oh I missed oh oh they see
me okay okay okay
remember hide okay if they can't see me
is it unfair to get someone at spawn
spawn camping is that Oh their cats
attacking me I will not fall for it I'm
thinking about it I wonder can I hold
there on the zipline we're gonna go for
it Lucy do it do it do it yeah
I fight Jay not okay all right all right
Jay not it's a rematch is it is that how
it is
fans oh they got me with free do they're
using Soros all right they can't see me
so they're using our bird boy frame so
they have spawned tornadoes that will
damage me if I get too close being that
you're using all the techniques at your
disposal they're using all the ones and
those it's not fair they actually can
cover themselves with wind and I can't
hit them with projectile weapons so I
don't know what I'm gonna do you other
than melee huh
that's my only option yeah alright Jana
where where did you go oh wow they fled
so it's May Laird oh my gosh they're too
agile and they're using little tornadoes
I feel like they've been using the whole
stream to plan for this final
confrontation
I know it's oh I got someone's pet can i
heavy attack cuz that would be one hit
kill for sure oh maybe not okay oh I
killed someone but it wasn't me it was
someone else that did it
all right Jana is better at this escape
plan thing than I am that's for sure I'm
sorry someone in the chat has a username
daddy stalker woo okay that's a great
finale if you ask me yeah Danny Zuko
someone's really mad at me do not touch
my dog grab I wasn't going for your dog
I swear I've honestly not it it's the
collateral damage I'm sorry I'm sorry
mr. creeper I'm looking for Jane odd but
they're too agile I honestly can't even
keep track of their name van because
they're just so fat I found them I found
them
okay I got their shields down again
Jonah hide under the stairs
they are the projectiles are useless
against them due to their turbulence
because they can just negate any and all
projectiles so melee is my only option
but they're there to agile for such
options oh gosh oh gosh I mean I mean a
lot spot here oh dear oh dear
yeah you got to see us okay
Jana is over here on the ground so
they've been not oh look at them making
their quick escape they're moving too
fast
they are zipping all over the place
can you believe it this is ridiculous
this is why we're not a PvP game first
this if I were the power fantasy is it's
okay where have they gone
we do have a bit more toned-down yeah I
keep killing that dog and I actually
feel bad now mr. creeper says it's on I
might need to go for mr. creeper Jana is
just you know they got me oh that was a
good match though actually I killed
Celestia that was my victory sorry
I think it's not like one each yeah
we'll give it one each one each which
okay
stalker daddy let's do a rope code
because they've been trying for a long
time and then well we'll end the stream
on the Rope cord is on an anchor I have
made it into a record session perfect
alright we got this this is this is the
fun to set the mini-boss before daddy
stalker
oh who was it who had the dog they just
put in YouTube chat I said do not touch
my dog alright
this rope cord has a pet name hoser
which is Canadian me try and get them
from above like this Oh hundred percent
huh damn it oh they see me I actually
didn't even know you could get up here
so this is this is impressive candy man
says he makes you very him very happy
oh that makes them very happy to read
fuses and Navi talk I believe is Jaina
says ha I survived that was a good game
you were one hit away from killing me
multiple times that now you understand
why I wanted to face you in an open
world I agree this is actually a pretty
intense battle right now here
anyone just saw that we just fell down
together from that giant cathedral
ceiling and it looked amazing when the
bow rock totally does Rebbe died yes she
does died and she is dead okay so uh the
community we've studied all your moves
Reb rabbit screams internally
all right daddy Stoker whoo how do you
feel saying that out loud
under a professional capacity I mean
it's it I didn't realize it would be
part of my job someday but I'm so happy
that it is here we go we're going in we
have a win we ran this is the grand
finale if you hit this by the way if you
get them that's a double because as ten
wins they have a full-on taraj here oh
are you seeing this
okay so you Laura spin with the
fantastic name and then you spring this
on us
daddy's theorists there's actually daddy
stocker oh and daddy soccer and we're
all here together I don't know what to
do they have a Trinity to keep them
alive she's our our healer class mm-hmm
and that's just not fair
oh they want screenshots okay all right
okay where do we go and then I get to
pick one of them to to be a sacrifice
there we go
daddy stalker okay very very good they
too have the gear on for such an
occasion very good very good they
prepped for this uh everyone in the chat
is doing FS faloona the dog Oh No so
then you know Luna didn't mean didn't
mean to die it was an accident all right
I'm not really sure how many if you're
listening this team I'm with would you
like me to attack or what is your
proposed finale here on this on this a
day fill the robot
yeah how tanky are our robots thank you
is this I said who stole them you're
killing me okay well thank you do you
want to do one more yes we did rope code
right
there's Zhen Visser Reiter is on Io
which is that's on Jupiter hmm all right
io Jupiter here we go if I don't
recognize the name I'm just gonna bail
cuz I don't want to hurt any innocent
people um I'm still in game with Luna
zona she's alive and well thanks for all
your thoughts prayers and F's thank you
thank you I am in a mission with morbid
crawly Danny plays and stalker and these
people aren't in on the joke no I will I
will I will perish
I will perish honor in an honor way it
will diminish and go into the West
all right kill me
oh I'll just shoot nothing I'll shoot
the wall just yeah oh I'm sorry sorry
crew okay they got me and they got my
glute so as always there is a happy
ending to such accidents yeah I'll be
down a couple more donations before we
before we end thank you to everyone
who's been watching and donating manuel
davies ten bucks to black lives matter
and matt Hawking who has been in a lot
of our streams and donating a bunch $10
- thank you so much and to Direct Relief
20 bucks from me - ooh who says thanks
for all the fun and laughs cynstalker
maghreb oh thank you for coming so once
it's the total tally here so I can make
notes so community wise I think they
beat you approximately 20 times okay
summer some of them were kind of like
we'll kind of attack you as you spawn in
oh you know will attack the roomba then
you flew in on
but you won nine times that's
respectable
very good that KTR is good is decent
alright so we'll do two I will make de
will be donating 29 times five to both
charities so we will happily be sending
those your way after the stream o.o make
sure to get them in thank you so much
and to everyone who's been watching and
donating thank you we'll be back again
tomorrow so we've got seven kam doing if
you have been following games for a long
time you'll know seven kam they're back
to do some more Skyrim mods and we have
Jack Pattillo is gonna be doing some
movie like a movie trivia quiz with us
which we're very excited for we have a
lot of cool things for the rest of the
week like rkg and fun house we're gonna
be raising money in this whole time Reb
thank you so much for joining us it's
been an absolute pleasure where can
people find you and what's up next for
you you know if you play warframe
there's gonna be the next month is gonna
be crazy
we're gonna be ramping up for 10 Oh con
so stay tuned on August 1st twitch.tv
slash warframe you will find some
madness and they are fraternal Khan so
don't miss it
perfect thank you so much and we'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]